republican senator ted cruz is a member
of the senate judiciary committee so
he'll be part of the confirmation
hearings
he's also on the president's list of
prospective nominees made before
this vacancy on the court senator cruz
good morning those were your words four
years ago
you don't believe that anymore well good
morning
it's good to be with you thank you for
having me uh
you know it's interesting if you look at
the debate four years ago
every single political player has
switched positions i looked at your clip
of politicians from 2016. you know you
didn't play
joe biden you didn't play hillary
clinton you didn't play nancy pelosi you
didn't play chuck schumer
why because every one of them is saying
exactly the opposite of what they're
saying now everyone has switched
positions and so the whole the whole
promo you're pushing about hypocrisy
if you want to say it you could say
everybody involved in this is a
hypocrite now so is that okay
i don't actually by the way we have
actually said that on this broadcast but
that doesn't matter
listen to your promo and you only played
the words of republicans i saw your
tweet
saying ted cruz why has he switched his
positions and i'm curious when you have
chuck schumer or joe biden on
does your tweet
but did you tweet and say why did they
change positions
we actually have but that doesn't you're
not answering the question of why you
didn't change that
i'm trying you're interrupting me i'm
trying to answer the question
go ahead everybody has changed their
positions every democrat has flipped but
there's actually a reason for that
which is both sides believe something
fundamentally different
about supreme court justices the
democrats and joe biden has promised to
nominate
liberal activist judges judges who will
undermine our free speech rights our
religious liberty rights our second
amendment rights
republicans president trump ran
promising to nominate principled
constitutionalists to the court the
american people elected him
the american people also elected a
republican majority not just once not
twice three times in 2014 2016 2018
the republican majority in the senate
ran promising to confirm
constitutionalist judges and if you
actually look at history
there's a clear pattern in history so we
can assess all right what typically
happens in this circumstance
this circumstance has arisen 29 times in
the history of our country 29 times
i don't want to go through the whole
history of this center but but hold on
hold on anthony because it actually is
like
really relevant for everything you're
saying you may not want to talk about it
but it's no i do want to talk about it
but
history takes a long time senator we
don't have that much time okay
you made the point four years ago this
hadn't happened in 80 years and i want
and i want to go to the point here too
that
that as you point out the president won
the election but he didn't win the
popular vote and the polls suggest that
62 percent of people
right now think the president next the
winner of this election should pick us
the supreme court justice what do you
say to that anthony here's what history
shows
whenever the president and the senate
are controlled by the same party
the senate almost always confirms
nominations in a presidential election
year it's happened 19 times
the senate has confirmed it 17 times
whenever the president
and the senate are controlled by
opposite parties as it was four years
ago with barack obama
the senate doesn't confirm the nominee
that's happened ten times in our history
the senate's only confirmed the nominee
twice now you know you may say that's
just a question of partisan power it's
actually not
it's a question of the people deciding
this issue was litigated
it was litigated to the american people
it was a major reason it was the single
biggest reason i personally voted for
donald trump is because he promised
to nominate justices in the mold of
scalia and thomas and
and if you if you want to understand the
stakes as you know i've got a new book
that is coming out
a week from today it's called one vote
away and it talks about what the supreme
court is all about how a single supreme
court seat can change history every
chapter
talks about a different constitutional
right and i spent my career before the
senate
before i was in the senate litigating
before the supreme court so the book
tells the inside war stories of the
landmark cases behind free speech and
religious liberty and the second
amendment
it tells what's really going on in a way
that is understandable in a way you
don't have to be a lawyer to understand
but if you care about the bill of rights
the book
one vote away it's available on amazon
right now for pre-order
will explain what the stakes are right
now in this choice
what's the name of that book again
senator cruz
one away one vote away okay so let's
pick up on that for a second are you
looking for a justice
who will strike down obamacare and
reverse roe v wade
yeah i'm looking for a justice who will
be
faithful to the law and the constitution
so there's an entire chapter you asked
about roe versus way there's an entire
chapter in the book
on the issue of life and and one of the
interesting things that a lot would you
like to see that reversed
would you like because we we don't have
the book yet so would you like to see it
reverse
i think roe versus wade was wrongly
decided but but here's a point very few
people understand
if roe versus wade were reversed the
consequent would would not
outlaw abortion it would simply return
to the way it was for most of the
history of our country which means
it would be decided by the state
legislatures each state
would make a different decisions
reflecting the values of their citizens
and here's the other point
and i talk about this at great length in
in the chapter on life in the book
um if joe biden gets
one additional liberal justice on the
court we're one vote away i i
rep litigated the federal partial birth
abortion case that's the federal law
that prohibits the really gruesome
practice of partial birth abortion
the court upheld that law 5-4 meant
there were four justices ready to strike
that down
and to say that you can have no
limitations whatsoever on abortion that
partial
birth abortion is mandated by the
constitution no parental consent no
parental notification those are extreme
positions
and and we're one vote away from that
that's what joe biden is promising and
that's not what the american people want
that's that's
far out of the mainstream senator
senators collins and murkowski have both
said
they would prefer this vote not happen
uh republicans
before the before the election uh
senator graham says
you already have the votes to pass the
supreme court nominee without even
knowing who it is
do you have the votes we do i i believe
we have the votes i don't know for sure
but
i believe we do and i think it's
critically important that we vote before
election day
and and let me tell you why joe biden
has already told us
that he intends to challenge the
legitimacy of this election if he
doesn't win an election day
he's hired a team of lawyers he plans to
bring lawsuits
challenging the election 20 years ago in
in the year 2000 we had bush versus gore
i i was part of the legal team
that represented george w bush in bush
bush versus gore in florida
there's a whole chapter in the book on
bush versus gore so if you want to
understand what could happen on election
day if joe biden challenged
us here's the critical point one last
point joe
okay a little bit just just let me just
get a sentence
uh well hillary clinton has told joe
biden
under no circumstances should you
concede that that's what she said
directly
senator the president has said that if
he doesn't win the election is a fake so
i mean okay they're going to be probably
challenges on both sides
of the election joe biden has but here's
the critical point senator
we've got unfortunately we have to go i
appreciate you being with us this
morning
and it's divided 4-4 it can't make a
decision we need a full court
to resolve that so we don't have a
constitutional crisis we don't have
chaos
but we don't want to see this election
republicans were okay with the court
being 4-4 for months after you wouldn't
even consider merrick garland
thank you senator cruz for being with us
this morning the candidate to challenge
the election like we do now